action un bon voilà alors moi je vais
faire un peu à contre-courant et
s'adapte et de générosité accouché en
fait je demande en examen qui elle peut
accoucher cette [ __ ]
je vais demander qu'on se tomber le vis
mon salaire par deux
seulement à isabelle comme solde de tout
compte isabelle si tu leur donnes
retraite
les lions
[Applaudissements]
c'est la série b webo et à la famille
des sites où l'on dormait
c'est fou non
c'est par là elles il allait la fin de
sa fiesta
on sera dans un instant ce qu'elle est à
ce que l'on pense à deux aces et créera
certainement tout cas
elle est méchante elle est allée à la
famille sortez nous avons
aimé arriver changer d'avis cause de ça
mais moi toujours j'entends un arrêt qui
doit se concentrer sur sur l'aide
est vraiment vraiment écrit ben ouais ça
s'écrit comme ça non classés doit se
concentrer sur l'être oui elle a oublié
la voix reprend il y en avoir dans quel
magasin qui pensent qu à posséder
acheter des voitures
et des montres des bagues des lunettes
posséder un consumérisme un peu maladif
qui cache quelque chose d'intimé rythme
je donne sa langue au sens de mes
cachets à l'association coloris sans
frontières
a trouvé un balayage de qualité
qui irait très bon bonsoir et mon bon
soir vous avez une très belle veston
dubuc et bien
non mais je vais faire en 10 secondes on
a la chance d'avoir le professeur qui
vient de temps en temps nous éclairer
sur l'île sur les vaccins à virologie
chacon avait autrefois kelly b devaient
lire à distance qui nous éclaire aussi
sur les vaccins mais on a un troisième
docteur sûrement la place qu'il fait ça
delphine avec qui est maintenant docteur
aussi dans les missions qui me parle
beaucoup du vaccin donc je veux diviser
son salaire par deux vu qu'elle docteur
maintenant
en tout cas
j'ai jamais dit que les docteurs je
donne juste la voix de ceux qui ne se
font pas actuellement est
finalement l'impression qu'on s'est
trompé il s'est encore plus méchant que
c'est fou hein mais j'aime bien rémi
délatté réalité et la vérité cyril
[Applaudissements]
m